Hi, I'm Brady.
I make the Numberphile videos
and there's just a few quick
messages I wanted to share.
Firstly, we had a bit of a
glitch this week, and it seems
our last video didn't go to
most of our subscribers.
And it's a really cool one,
it's a collaboration with
ViHart all about tetrahedral
dice.
If you don't know what I'm
talking about, or haven't seen
it, you may not have gone it,
and I'll put a link under the
video and on the screen.
Next, I just want to say
something about our notorious
bits of brown paper.
You see them all the
time in our videos.
And this is a whole bunch
from previous films.
Some people love them and
some people hate them.
I've written a blog about why I
use it, so I'm not going to
cover it again now, but I just
wanted you to know--
let me grab something
here, hang on.
This particular piece, it's
the Nepalese flag from our
video about the most
mathematical flag in the world.
Well that's actually
up for auction at
the moment, on eBay.
We're raising money
for charity.
If you're interested, and would
like to own this piece
of Numberphile history, why
don't you put in a bid?
And if it proves popular, maybe
some of those other ones
could go to charity as well.
Next, I just wanted to mention
a video that was sent in by a
viewer when we were doing all
our Rubik's cube films.
It's one that I really meant to
show everyone at the time,
but didn't really
get the chance.
So I just want to highlight
it now.
Basically it's from a guy called
either Shy or Shay, I'm
not sure how to pronounce his
name, but he's got a whole
bunch of Rubik's cubes
of different style.
And he managed to make them say
Numberphile, and then he
solved every single
one of them.
And I reckon that's pretty
amazing, and
worth a special mention.
While we're having this chat, I
thought this might be a good
opportunity to hear what you
want us to making films about.
So why not use this video, in
the comments section below, to
give us some suggestions and
tell us more about what you'd
like to say.
Lastly, I don't normally do
these sort of messages in
videos, but I do let people
know what's going on via
Twitter and Facebook.
You can follow us on there.
There's always a little bit
extra, pictures, chances to
get involved.
So sign up for those, if you're
that kind of social
media person.
A reminder again, if you didn't
see the ViHart video,
links are below.
And under the video, I'm going
to put loads to all my other
channels, because some of you
don't realize, when I'm not
obsessing about numbers, I've
got a whole bunch of other
videos about chemistry, and
astronomy, and physics.
You can check them out too.
Thanks for watching.
I'm actually flying off to San
Francisco now, but I'll be
back next week, putting up
new Numberphile videos.